taxons arrivée sur notre sol aujourd'hui
et dès demain ils seront administrés
dans deux ehpad que dans le coin sur
fond d'inquiétude en raison du rebond de
l'épidémie et la détection d'une souche
mutante à tours ce qui relance de plus
belle le spectre d'un confinement
les chefs d'état de la communauté
économique des états de l'afrique
centrale ceeac envisage l'envoi de
troupes en centrafrique
elle appelle les centrafricains à voter
massivement demain et condamne la mort
de trois casques bleus beau rendez-vous
pertes à laquelle s'ajoutent plusieurs
blessés dans ce contexte sécuritaire
tendu des élections générales doivent se
tenir demain
signera signera pas d'un altra maintient
le suspense après ces menaces du veto le
président américain a jusqu'à lundi soir
pour signer le plan de relance
économique post coville 900 milliards de
dollars dette pour éviter à des millions
d'américains de se retrouver sur le
carreau
il ya aussi un risque de chutes d'arbres
pour l'administration du pays qui
risquent de fermer
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france les premiers
vaccins fighter biotech sont arrivés
aujourd'hui en france des milliers de
doses à la pharmacie centrale des
hôpitaux de paris à nanterre elles
seront administrés dès demain dans deux
établissements pour personnes âgées à à
sevran et à dijon par ailleurs on a
recensé le premier cas du virus mutant
sur le territoire à tour il s'agit d'un
homme arrivé de londres le 19 décembre
selon la direction générale de la santé
asymptomatiques qu'il a été placé à
l'isolément à son domicile plusieurs
selon plusieurs études
la nouvelle souche est plus contagieuse
mais rien ne démontre à ce stade qu'elle
entraîne des formes plus grave de la
maladie
elle serait d'ailleurs maîtrisé par le
vaccin angoisse là avec walid bennani
quatre gammes de températures
15 25 degrés 5° moins 20 degrés au moins
80 dollars
on est coincé moins 80 qui matin le
ministre de la santé tout sourire mardi
dernier olive et veyran en déplacement
au coeur de la plateforme logistique de
chanteloup en brie en seine et marne
la france prête à recevoir des millions
de premières doses du vaccin fader
biotech contre le coronavirus avec des
supers congélateur sa danse là dedans il
ya mille donne quand même une idée de du
volume de stockage grâce si énorme que
ça donne le compte à rebours a commencé
en réalité depuis le départ de ces
petites fioles de belgique et des
laboratoires pfizer de possibilités
d'acheminement ensuite dans l'hexagone
réception des deux au sein de six
plateformes spécialisées comme celle de
chanteloup ambri autre possibilité des
dépôts vers une centaine de sites dont
la plupart hospitalier un par
département avec toujours les précieux
au congélateur pour les garder au frais
la décharge box est sorti le carton
jaune à cinq jours pour pouvoir
fanni serait pas que ça avec impatience
cela maintenant leur commence à tourner
imaginons que ces vaccins ils doivent
aller aux bouleversements en voir au
bout de la région
moins de douze heures de transport
autorisé un stockage avoir lieu sécurisé
le court possible
et puisse être ensuite envoyées
directement en l'occurrence dans l'ehpad
et cette famille sera au moins cinq
jours
au total
la population des ehpad cible numéro 1
du gouvernement plus de 14000 collectif
pour personnes âgées en métropole et
outre-mer sont concernés une première
phase qui devrait s'étendre jusqu'en
février avec la réception de plus de
trois millions de doses d'un horizon de
24 à 48 heures nous diffuserons avant un
guide de recommandations de bonne
pratique pour les établissements
accueillant des personnes âgées
dépendantes pour les ehpad
s'agissant de la vaccination et des
modalités de recueil du consentement
nous avons fait le choix en france qui
est un choix qu'il assume et revendique
et de prendre le consentement des
personnes qui seront vaccinés la
vaccination n'est pas obligatoire de
faire un examen médical préalable une
deuxième étape entre février et mars
2021 pour certains professionnels de
santé et personnes présentant notamment
des pathologies chroniques troisième
phase à la fin du printemps la
vaccination sera ouverte aux 50 millions
de français restant avec en ligne de
mire les secteurs les plus exposés comme
ceux de la santé l'éducation et celui de
l'anim entière de repos obligatoire
martet le gouvernement mais un futur
projet de loi sur les urgences
sanitaires qui fait polémique
le premier ministre pourrait à l'avenir
suspendre certains déplacements des
français
un test de dépistage un traitement ou
encore l'administration d'un vaccin
deviendraient nécessaires
que cache emmanuel macron je croyais
naïvement que dans notre patrie le
respect des libertés étaient la règle et
ses restrictions l'exception là
l'exécutif aurait tout pouvoir porter ce
prendre nos libertés sans contrôle du
parlement
inconcevable de façon sournoise ce texte
envisage non pas de rendre la
vaccination obligatoire mais d'empêcher
toute vie sociale aux personnes qui ne
le serait pas quand il s'agit de
restreindre nos libertés publiques
on pourrait avoir une discussion
collective tout de même face à cette
fronde le gouvernement frein promis que
ce projet de loi ne serait pas examinée
devant le parlement avant plusieurs mois
et la fin de la crise a dit
et la défiance à des français vis-à-vis
du vaccin augmente 40% d'entre eux
disent vouloir se faire vacciner selon
santé publique française étaient 53%
il ya un mois et demi on écoute
christophe prudhomme médecin urgentiste
délégué cgt santé et porte parole de
l'association médecins urgentistes de
france
on pourra pas vacciner la population
avec un dispositif auxi complexe que
celui là j'espère que d'autres vaccins
plus facile à transporter pourront être
rapidement disponible autrement je pense
qu'on va vite être en difficulté au
niveau personnel et mobilisations
nécessaires
les amendes autre chose à faire il faut
qu'on s'occupe des autres patients
et vous savez le problème sur ce vaccin
c'est la confiance et la confiance et
bien c'est avec le médecin traitant
l'infirmière le personnel qu'on connaît
pas ce gros dispositif très compliqué
qui n'est pas très rassurant quand même
pour la population or il faut rassurer
la population sur le fait que nous avons
besoin de nous faire vacciner
et si possible effectivement qu'on soit
vacciné le plus rapidement possible et
pas uniquement les personnes en ehpad
vous savez les personnes à risque sont
toutes les personnes de plus de 65 ans
et pas uniquement c dans les pales
or là le dispositif en plusieurs étapes
interroge une partie des personnes âgées
en particulier celles qui ne sont pas en
ehpad qu'ils sont à domicile et qui
aimerait bien pouvoir se faire vacciner
assez rapidement
on en vient la situation en centrafrique
à la veille des élections générales
aujourd'hui une conférence virtuelle a
réuni les chefs d'état d'afrique
centrale une réunion de la ceeac la
communauté économique des états de
l'afrique centrale qui demande à ses
membres d'envoyer des troupes sur place
elle appelle à également les
centrafricains à se rendre massivement
aux urnes demain et condamne aussi la
mort de trois casques bleus bondé tués
dans une attaque on fait le point avec
pierre jan mazari avec pas comme pas
bandji il était censé assurer le
maintien de la paix dans le pays
al'approche des élections trois casques
bleus burundais ont été tués et deux
autres blessés dans les villes de déco à
et bakouma en république centrafricaine
des pertes déplorées par l'onu le
secrétaire général condamne fermement
les attaques perpétrées aujourd'hui par
des éléments non identifiés visant les
forces de défense et de sécurité
centrafricaine et la mission multi
dimensionnelle intégré des nations unies
pour la stabilisation en république
centrafricaine avant cela la minustah
avait pourtant reçu le soutien de 300
casques bleus rwandais supplémentaires
une situation tendue alors que le pays
s'apprête à élire son président et ses
140 députés dans un climat de guerre
civile
l'état d'afrique centrale est contrôlé
en majeure partie par des groupes armés
qui mènent depuis une semaine des
combats dans certaines villes du pays
pour déstabiliser l'élection
pourtant mercredi si encourageants deux
des principales factions rebelles
avaient décrété un cessez le feu de
trois jours une trêve finalement rompu
un jour avant la date butoir
face à l'entêtement irresponsable du
gouvernement de rejeter le cessez le feu
la coalition des patriotes pour le
changement décide de rompre la trêve de
72 heures qu'elle s'était jusque-là
imposé et de reprendre sa marche
implacable jusqu'à son objectif final
désormais soit le gouvernement nous
disperse
soit nous marchons sur bangui malgré la
menace d'une offensive sur la capitale
par les rebelles
le président sortant et favori à sa
réélection faustin archange touadéra
exclut tout report du vote
la minus qu'à elle
se veut rassurante et à viande que les
groupes armés sont pour l'instant tenus
à distance et nous sommes avec jean
serge bokassa l'un des chiffes de l'axé
emploi jean-bedel bokassa
bonsoir à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france vous avez retiré
votre candidature jean serge avocat ça
mais la cour constitutionnelle a
invalidé votre demande de retrait demain
vous n'irait pas voter c'est ce que vous
affirmez pour quelles raisons tout
simplement parce que je ne veux pas
cautionner ce que je considère comme
étant une mascarade électorale qui pis
est exposé la vie de nos concitoyens à
des risques évidents
je pense que les informations que vous
avez telles que je les ai écoutés telles
que je les ai vus dans votre journal ne
présente une situation par ses nerfs de
la réalité sécuritaire qui lie en
république centrafricaine
il ya de nombreuses régions aujourd'hui
qu'ils sont occupés par des groupes
armés et nos concitoyens seront tout
simplement dans l'impossibilité d'aller
voter
donc outre le fait qu'il ya eu un grand
nombre d'irrégularités qui ont été donc
relever et pour lesquels aucune suite
n'a été donnée
il ya aujourd'hui cette donne
sécuritaire qui me semble être
extrêmement importante et qui ne peut
pas permettre qu'une élection se tienne
donc de ce fait là je ne souhaite pas
cautionner cela
c'est une forme de parodies électorales
de parodie d'élection qui je pense
renferme
d'entrée de jeu les germes des futures
conclut que nous allons connaître
pourtant donné pourtant en 2016 la
situation elle n'était pas si différente
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut quand même
préciser c'est que les forces onusiennes
affirme que la situation elle est sous
contrôle même s'il vous l'avez dit c'est
vrai il ya des groupes armés qui sont
actifs quand même à l'intérieur du pays
quelle est la différence avec la
avec 2016 à l'époque aussi on sortait
d'une transition et l'élection s'est
tenue tout de même dans des conditions
compliquées aussi s'écrire sur le plan
sécuritaire écoutez c'est à dire que la
situation est complètement différente de
celle de 2015 2016
il y avait d'abord premièrement il y
avait moins de propre armée sur le
territoire donc c'est quand même assez
surprenant que durant les cinq années de
mandat de monsieur faustin archange
touadéra il ya eu une prolifération des
groupes armés à nous sommes passés de
près de 4 à 5 groupes armés à quatorze
groupes armés aujourd'hui ce qui est
assez surprenant c'est le premier point
le second point c'est que pendant les
élections 2015 2016
il y avait une trêve qui était observé
par les groupes armés aucun groupe armé
le s'est mise au travers du processus
électoral ce qui me semble être une
bonne extrêmement importante
j'en viens maintenant plan de
sécurisation du processus électoral
moi qui fus qui tique était candidat qui
ne suis manifestement toujours 1 suite à
la décision de la cour constitutionnelle
je n'ai pas eu un seul élément de
sécurité durant tout ce durant toute la
campagne
alors vous voyez bien qu'il ya des
disparités qui sont évidentes des
traitements qui sont évidents on vit de
réalité totalement différentes la
réalité du camp qui est au pouvoir qui
jouit des privilèges liés justement à
responsabilités qu'ils occupent
aujourd'hui au sommet de l'état et la
réalité d'un peuple est totalement
abandonnée mais moi je peux parler pour
ce peuple abandonné et je vais
m'identifier à ce peuple abandonné mais
je fais acte de solidarité vis-à-vis
d'eux si l'ex ministre un de la sécurité
de l'actuel président justement sur le
plan sécuritaire il ya des groupes armés
qui sont ces groupes armés qui les
contrôle qui est à la manette si je veux
dire parce qu'on a accusé aussi l'ex
chef de l'état françois bozizé d'avoir a
tenté un coup d'état dans votre pays et
on sait que vous l'avez soutenu françois
bozizé aussi on le préfet avant sa chute
un oui mais écoutez je pense que il faut
il faut arrêter de je pense de ce
produit la face le président faustin
archange touadéra quand il parle de sa
politique de la main tendue à qui il
tend la main
yakima tant pis lama durant cinq ans si
ce n'est à ses chefs
groupes armés qui aujourd'hui se
retourne contre lui alors la question
c'est à lui qu'il faut la poser qui sont
séchées est responsable de quoi
la question que l'on peut poser c'est
pourquoi ces groupes armés se retourne
contre lui aujourd'hui alors qu'ils ont
signé ces groupes
un accord l'accord de cartoon on s'en
souvient en 2019
la formation que je que je dirige
aujourd'hui s'est toujours érigé contre
les accords de khartoum qui consacrait
qui consacre d'ailleurs toujours une
actualité totale à ces groupes armés la
voilà les résultats aujourd'hui de cet
accord du cateau nous en voyons ici
toutes les insuffisances
voilà les résultats de la politique de
la main tendue du président faustin
archange touadéra qui en cinq ans
manifestement n'a pas pu rapporter la
paix alors que c'est ce que le
centrafricain demande prioritairement
alors je vois pas ce qu'il va apporter
d'autres avant cinq années
supplémentaires
je dis tout simplement dire vous n'avez
pas répondu concernant la laine et
l'éventuelle responsabilité de françois
bozizé qui menait une coalition de
l'opposition la coalition à cod 2020 qui
m'aimait pardon il menait une coalition
il était le chef d'une coalition de
l'opposition cod 2020 ou comme lanvin
selon l'opposition le code le côte
sauvage non je n'en fais pas partie
madame mouvement n'en fait pas partie
nous n'avons jamais souscrit à intégrer
ou contraints va j'ai toujours essayé de
défendre des idées qui sont les miennes
avec les convictions qui sont les
miennes
ils se trompent comptabilité de françois
bozizé com quelle est votre position là
dessus mais écoutez la responsabilité de
françois bozizé reste la responsabilité
de françois bozizé si aujourd'hui boe
estime le chemin qui l'attend au chaud
c'est le chemin qui est consacrée à marc
du président faustin archange touadéra
c'est le chemin qui est consacrée
éventuellement par ceux qui sont censés
représenter la communauté internationale
de notre pays c'est aujourd'hui voilà
voilà l'école qui est la nôtre
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on apprend à
respecter les chefs de groupes armés
n'est pas les citoyens qui aujourd'hui
sont en quête de paix ah c'est la triste
réalité de notre pays
donc je ne suis pas moi personnellement
je ne porte aucun caution à ceux à ce
type d'approché l'a d'ailleurs je je
j'ai toujours été un fervent défenseur
des valeurs démocratiques dans mon pays
un jeu reste un pacifiste engagé et je
condamne d'ailleurs les tout ce qui va
dans le sens
une prise de pouvoir par la force dans
mon pays mais de grâce nous imputer pas
des responsabilités sur des sujets
aujourd'hui dont on est complètement
ignorant ceux qui aujourd'hui sont enfin
la prédominance à la prédominance des
groupes armés puisque vous avez été vous
même ministre de la sécurité
aujourd'hui il ya une conférence
virtuelle de la semaine passée la
communauté économique des états de
l'afrique centrale qui demande aussi la
levée de l'embargo sur les armes
concernant la centrafrique saint-ex que
la france a soutenues à l'onu il ya eu
une abstention lors du vote de la chine
et de la russie sur ce texte
est-ce que la levée de cet embargo
pourrait justement permettre à l'armée
de mieux se professionnalise et de
pouvoir de créer une armée pérenne
fasseur justement à la situation
sécuritaire inquiétante dans votre pays
je pense qu'il faut non seulement la
levée de l'embargo je suis un patriote
vous savez j'aime mon pays et je pense
important de restaurer une banque
l'aîné des institutions et les missions
qui sont censés les soutenir comme celle
de l'armée nationale s'exprime important
maintenant je pense également que la
lampe l'embargo vous allez aujourd'hui
permettre à notre armée nationale d'être
en condition de pouvoir mener ses
missions mais lorsqu'on tient compte des
accords de khartoum qui aujourd'hui
permettent sous fonce en sorte que nos
forces d'armes armées centrafricaines
son temps à faire des missions
conjointes avec justement des rebelles
pour soi-disant pacifié notre territoire
alors comment voulez vous concilier cela
c'est inconciliables je pense que
l'embargo il faut lever mais avec un
gouvernement responsable et une
orientation politique totalement
différente si mon point de vue hélas
évincé qui envisageraient aussi de 2
d'envoyer des troupes en centrafrique on
sait que parmi ses membres il ya quand
même des pays qui se sent concerné par
la situation de votre pays on peut citer
par exemple le congo-k est un ancien
médiateur mais aussi le tchad voisin qui
a une frontière sud avec la république
centrafricaine est ce que vous souhaitez
vous que peut laisser à ces bouges
justement comme moi je souhaiterais
premièrement aujourd'hui qu'on permette
au centrafrique a dû discuter avec eux
mêmes et de d'arrivée eux mêmes à
trouver les solutions les plus
appropriées pour leur pays on a été
assisté par plusieurs groupes par
plusieurs armée multinationale
ils sont d'ailleurs un grand nombre sur
notre territoire ça ne change absolument
rien la politique de la main tendue du
président de la république n'a changé
absolument rien il faut premièrement
qu'on donne le soin que je pense ou
pourquoi au centre africain de se
retrouver véritablement avec eux-mêmes
et de définir ce qui aujourd'hui peut
contribuer à ramener la paix dans leur
pays un dialogue inter centre africain
s'impose s'impose véritablement des
fonds des solutions politiques et
ensuite envisager pourquoi pas des
solutions qui peuvent être entre
guillemets on va dire militaire presse
que jusqu'ici la solution militaire n'a
pas apporté grand chose on a un problème
de justice madame dans ce pays un
problème de justice il faut arrêter de
consacrer l'impunité
je pense que si la solution n'est pas
forcément militaire et peut-être
policière et elle doit être judiciaire
aujourd'hui je pense que le désert qui
s'est installée dans notre pays relève
uniquement du rétablissement de l'ordre
de l'ordre public et de son maintien
maintien de la paix on n'a pas besoin
forcément d'avoir défini des forces
armées impressionnante dans notre pays
c'est du grand banditisme qui s'est
installée dans notre pays et qui s'est
finalement structurés merci à vous jean
serge bokassa je rappelle que vous avez
retiré votre candidature pour cette
présidentielle et vous êtes l'un des
fils de l'ancien empereur jean-bedel
bokassa merci à vous
autre élection des élections générales
également au niger mme trentaine de
candidats est un favori pour la
présidentielle mohamed bazoum
le dauphin du président mahamadou
issoufou plusieurs priorités également
le développement économique social mais
aussi la sécurité est enclavé du sahel
le niger subi des attaques de groupes
terroristes différents et lundi une
patrouille de l'armée est tombée dans
une embuscade tendue par à des
terroristes sept militaires ont été tués
elle les nigériens attendent donc
beaucoup de celui qui prendra à la tête
du pays à david kadouch des visages
inquiet un avenir incertain et un
sentiment d'insécurité permanent voilà à
quoi ressemble le quotidien des
habitants de diffa cette ville du sud
est du niger à la frontière avec le
nigeria vit en état de siège
un responsable boko haram et ces
dissidences conséquence la population et
apeurée est prise à la gorge
économiquement non la vie ici à des
femmes c'est pas facile
rui da la sécurité on n'a pas d'emploi
la dégradation du climat
l'élevage l'agriculture le commerce
tout ça ça ne va pas le travail on en a
pas tout ça c'est à cause de
l'insécurité vraiment surtout surtout du
de la mauvaise gouvernance de nos pays
de nos pas la personne n'ose prononcer
le nom du groupe islamiste nigérian par
peur de représailles
boko haram a des oreilles partout un
rêve pour ces nigériens retrouver leur
domicile
en effet la région de diffa accueille
trois cent mille réfugiés et déplacés du
niger et du nigeria selon les chiffres
de l'onu
une situation insoutenable et un enjeu
considérable pour cette offre
[Musique]
mohamed bazoum incarna mince espoir pour
une gouvernance différentes favori de
cette élection présidentielle le
successeur annoncé de mahamadou issoufou
fait un pari osé ramener dans leurs
villages d'origine d'ici fin 2021
les centaines de milliers de déplacés et
réfugiés fuyant les violences de boko
haram dans le sud est du pays
issu d'une ethnie minoritaire ce
travailleur acharné aura s'il est élu un
défi colossal rétablir l'ordre et la
sécurité dans son pays
la séance est renforcé nos forces de
sécurité el de lieux nous avons un
programme de thomas nous avons mise en
le recrutement de jeunes gens de la
région du lac tchad de la région du
divin du moins les gens ont été formés
pensons que avec des personnes qui
seront vraiment opérationnel tout à fait
au point suivant les sites le dossier
sécuritaire avec les quatre autres pays
du g5 sel est la priorité du futur
gouvernement
l'éducation sera le fer de lance de ce
projet ambitieux pour éviter que les
camps de réfugiés deviennent des repères
jihadistes
les quelques 7,4 millions de nigériens
appelés aux urnes ce dimanche veulent du
concret pour pouvoir espérer retrouver
une vie normale aux états unis
maintenant il ne reste plus que 48
heures à donald trump pour signer le
plan de relance économique post coded le
locataire de la maison blanche a jusqu'à
lundi soir pour ratifier le texte
dans le cas contraire des milliers
d'américains pourraient se retrouver sur
le carreau l'administration risque en
shot down une fermeture ont fait le
point avec guy marrot vit une fin de
règne mouvementé
à moins d'un mois de son départ de la
maison blanche donald trump demeure
fidèle à son style présidentiel quitte à
s'aliéner son propre camp l'un des
derniers dossiers sensibles en date
l'adoption du budget de la défense le
président américain est farouchement
opposé à la version adoptée par le
parlement
et ya mis son veto ce mercredi qu'à cela
ne tienne les deux chambres
y compris donc le sénat pourtant
majoritairement républicain ont annoncé
un vote dans les prochains jours pour
outrepasser le veto présidentiel
un véritable camouflet pour la maison
blanche plus important encore l'adoption
du plan de relance de l'économie
américaine pour faire face aux
conséquences de l'épidémie de covin 19
le texte prévoyait initialement
d'allouer une aide financière de 600
euros aux américains en difficulté
trop peu selon donald trump je demande
au congrès d'amendé ce projet de loi est
d'augmenter les ridiculement faible 600
$ à 2
mille dollars ou 4000 $ pour un couple
je demande également au congrès de se
débarrasser des éléments inutiles et
coûteux de cette loi et de m'envoyer un
projet de loi appropriée
sinon ce sera la prochaine
administration qui sera chargé de
fournir un plan de relance qu vide
une annonce qui a pris de court les élus
républicains les démocrates eux ont
sauté sur l'occasion et ont déposé ce
jeudi un amendement en ce sens et si
donald trump n'a pas prononcé le mot
veto nous la washington ne doute qu'ils
soient déterminées à en user pour
certains il pourrait s'agir d'une
vengeance du locataire de la maison
blanche
plusieurs sénateurs républicains ont en
effet récemment reconnu la victoire de
joe biden aux élections de novembre
une trahison pour le président
républicain qui n'a de cesse de
contester les résultats du scrutin et de
crier à la fraude
j'ai sauvé au moins huit sénateurs
républicains dont mitch dont la défaite
lors de la dernière élection
présidentielle truquée maintenant ils
s'assoient presque tous et me regarde de
me battre contre un ennemi tordu et
vicieux les démocrates radicaux de
gauche
je n'oublierai jamais les républicains
ont annoncé mercredi qu'il n'accèderait
pas à la requête de donald trump
d'augmenter les aides aux américains
la situation est donc dans l'impasse
d'autant que le plan de relance est lié
au budget du gouvernement pour 2021
la perspective du veto présidentiel fait
ainsi planer la menace d'un nouveau choc
town c'est à dire un arrêt partiel des
activités gouvernementales et du même
coup la suspension du versement des
salaires de nombreux fonctionnaires
il y a deux ans un désaccord entre
donald trump et le congrès avait déjà
débouché sur une situation similaire le
shutdown avait alors duré plus d'un mois
le plus long de l'histoire des états
unis
effet la fin de ce journal merci à vous
de l'avoir suivi on a retrouvé en direct
dans 30 minutes
restez avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde même si on
n'est pas en appartement on est énervé
grenelle